hello I'm agenda for executive vice
president and the member of the founding
management team at accretive health the
fastest growing IT company in healthcare
in the United States what keeps me
motivated solve an interesting and
challenging business problems
principally when they have an
international convention like here in
Latin America most interested India
heard the world economic forum today
ties with youth employment Latin America
is one a combination of good government
policies at Southern Living pursue here
in Brazil at the Kerner ship and a very
active role by Luke latinas or emerging
multinationals Norwegian helped create
hundreds of thousands of jobs Olivia
youth unemployment and simple can
contribute to access to the middle
classes of dead thousands of millions of
people who used to live in poverty it
was very impressed by the statistics
that say that
last 10 years Brazil has brought 36
million people out of poverty to the
middle class its youth participation
important economic development America
absolutely democra fix in this version
of oil estonian that's both asset and a
responsibility for all concerned large
companies and to panera companies and
governors what can be done in this area
and what their personally been involved
with I think there is only an increasing
role by a private capital McElveen
venture capitalists from the u.s. to
help foster and create funding options
for young entrepreneurial company and
preserve in Argentina and Chile Colombia
and Peru I'm involved with that
community and labor from San Francisco
California and have established some
contacts here at the forum to create
some bridges between venture capital
community in Silicon Valley in
California in interesting new
entrepreneurial ideas near South America
for example you can touch personal auto
connect you